would you settle a score against a
crappy store turns out customer problems
with products and services is higher
than ever before surprise a recent
survey found that 74 said they've had
problems with both in the last year the
number one product people are most
unhappy with
[Laughter]
action too usually through public
shaming or pestering them in person or
online you know it's how Janet Yellen
got even with her hair stylist
couldn't work again but when it comes to
handling these complaints customers say
certain businesses handle it better than
others sectors like banking food
delivery and package delivery do well so
does by masseuse but
he uses too much knuckle
it's not knuckle
sorry sorry it's a comedy show it's a
comedy show
but things like pay TV automotive and
air travel not so much that makes sense
I'm pretty sure Spirit would put seats
on the outside of the plane if they
could One customer service strategy that
seems to piss people off the most having
to listen to a robot before you can
speak to an actual person
but I guess now we know how white White
House reporters feel
but maybe this is why more companies
should employ married men they're well
trained to deal with nagging
uh Aaron have you ever publicly shamed a
company like there's a time where
everybody was like going on Twitter and
actually I used to make fun of it but
then if that's your only Outlet to get
to a rent like Budget rent a car like my
car's not here have you ever done that I
don't believe I have done that but now
I'm sure someone's like going to go
through my Twitter history and be like
Oh yeah this one time but I don't
remember doing that but I'd like to
welcome the private sector to the public
sector there are staff assistants and
interns on Capitol Hill that get
screamed out on the phone every day all
summer long all of the time and people
were locked up all through 2020 so
they're coming out swinging now yeah and
they are just they're angry they want
retribution they want things to go well
and if you're a Bravo fan there's a big
Scandal right now that Tom Sandoval one
of the guys on Vanderpump Rules cheated
on his girlfriend and Yelp had to shut
down the reviews for his restaurant
because Bravo fans were going on there
and just dragging the rating down by
giving him one stars because he cheated
on his girlfriend you know what you just
did you just explained to me this whole
story that I had no idea what it was but
it's always in the New York Post yes and
I'm going who is Sandoval who are these
people I've never heard of these people
and it just shows you there's no
connection between Bravo and fox it's my
patriotic Duty I'm glad to be here to do
this little did you know big Bravo fan
and yeah people Yelp has had to shut
down uh the restaurant rating because
people are angry and taking it that's
amazing you just describe I should hire
you to explain things to me you know all
right Charles the point about the the
shutdown is created Angry people but
it's also screwed up customer service
right because there was like this there
was the what do you call it the uh
pipeline was all screwed up and nobody
was working right right you couldn't get
what you wanted what do you make of this
you know I think first and foremost
let's be honest products and services
suck these days it's awful I hate say
that's just we've gone to crap I mean
there was a product and you get stuff
almost anything I buy or see or service
I know it's going to be it's not going
to live up to my expectations so
a week ago I ordered two croissant egg
sandwiches my wife is at church I'm like
all right you know I'm hungry I can't
wait for her to get back from church you
succeeded what they brought me they
brought me a banquet for about 60 people
three bags Large Ass slabs I'm like so I
call the restaurant they're like well
call GrubHub I call GrubHub I guess
someone overseas what do you want what
do you want I'm like I want two egg
sandwiches
I call a restaurant back like someone's
gonna be pissed off someone's having a
wedding I mean
but like oh you
know this happened
I'm like did you keep the food yeah we
uh you know what so we hadn't like
my nephew came by later on that day to
take down the Christmas tree he lives in
some kind of hovel thing with like about
40 other people said take the food my
man so it worked out great
except I didn't eat I was hungry as hell
almost all day until she got home but
that you know so it's just tough I mean
the services suck these days man I want
Charles to just tell me stories for the
rest of my life cat um do you agree
though that you nodded when you said all
products and services sucked you do you
sure do
and you've got to go public because
that's the only way that you can have
any hope at Justice like on this show
when I talked about my mushy onion and
my spoiled slimy or my spoiled slimy
onion and mushy green pepper yeah that I
got from ubereats grocery and then I end
up having to go out and get the stuff
which means I did not receive the
service I paid for which is to be able
to stay home I did stay home and my
husband go get it but like that's
besides the point no that's I didn't
receive it and then I talked about it on
this show and then I I posted it on
Twitter and then ubereats replied like
oh no nobody likes the slimy onion
um we can always DM us I'm like don't
Gaslight me I was so pissed off because
that's not what the two customer service
people I talked to said they said this
is your policy I did not accept their
offer I did not because that is not
justice as long as they continue this
fraudulent thieving policy that is that
is not fair because I paid for something
I did not receive I got it I order
something you don't get it that's fraud
right it's fraudulent and now you've
made a lifelong enemy Rob yeah I I kind
of feel that this is turning everybody
into George Costanza yeah there's a lot
of anger over there I don't think it's
about ubereats or like your croissant
sandwich I think something else is going
on you see the evil but I gotta tell you
uh just an alternate perspective I was
expecting a package it said I got the
Texas delivered it wasn't there I was
really really angry and I said to the
email back I didn't hear anything I got
very angry I called it was going to be
you know six minutes on hold I finally
said yeah I'm gonna tweet so I tweeted
at the place and then we got in this DM
it's not there it's not there could you
maybe check to see if it's behind the
gate it's not behind the gate
and then I went behind the gate and
there it was so it to my credit though
I I owned up to it by um deleting all
the tweets and then blocking them
ah yes don't you hate complaining part
of the problem that's the worst
complaint I'd like to think that I am
the whole problem yeah complaining about
something and then finding out you were
wrong is the worst thing ever that
always happens when I'm ordering food
and they got wise where is it and it's
like as I'm on the phone or they're like
it shows up I have video footage of my
slimy onion well I am on the right you
gotta go all right euphemism yes doctor
I have a slimy onion all right drop your
pants
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else